Istora Mandiri: Hello, everyone.
Istora Mandiri: I think you're on mute, Weigo.
weder: Yo, can you hear me?
Istora Mandiri: Yeah. Can you hear me?
weder: Yeah, I got you.
Istora Mandiri: Awesome.
weder: They're going.
Istora Mandiri: It's going very well, thanks.
Istora Mandiri: Thanks for joining, good to see you.
Istora Mandiri: How are you?
weder: It's my pleasure. Thanks for, doing it at a, you know, more… better time. Usually it's at the opposite time of the day, 11pm. It's not… not great for… I don't know, maybe, I guess it's because you're on the other side of the world. But what changed today?
Istora Mandiri: Today we are in Europe. I'm in Europe, and I'm here with Diego, who's also in Europe. Yes, hello.
weder: Oh, he's actually there!
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, yeah, awesome.
Istora Mandiri: I do.
weder: Diego.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, hi, how are you?
weder: Doing very well.
Istora Mandiri: And, we go, I see he's in the room.
Istora Mandiri: How you doing?
Istora Mandiri: We can't hear you.
Istora Mandiri: I think there's a mic setting that might need to be tweaked.
w1g0: Can you hear me now?
Istora Mandiri: Yes.
Istora Mandiri: Got ya.
w1g0: Great.
Istora Mandiri: Thank you for joining.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, there's no green room this week, because, yeah, we've been…
Istora Mandiri: in Europe at a conference, and bit tight on time, so I think we'll just jump into it straight away.
Istora Mandiri: So… In a few seconds, I'll kick things off.
Istora Mandiri: Okay, hello and welcome to Ethereum Classic Community Call number 54. Today is Friday, 12th of June, 2026.
Istora Mandiri: Ethereum Classic Community Calls is a voice chat discussion about Ethereum Classic, and everyone is welcome.
Istora Mandiri: The call will be published on YouTube, so we kindly ask that discussion stays focused on ideas rather than individuals, and let's keep it classy.
Istora Mandiri: You can find past episodes, transcripts, subscribe to the calendar, and more at cc.theoremclassic.org.
Istora Mandiri: This week is a bit of a special episode. Today, I'm joined in person with Diego. Yup. Hello, everyone.
Istora Mandiri: Hi, Diego. Yeah, happy to be here. It's very strange…
Istora Mandiri: Not having latency between us, and being able to speak in real time.
Istora Mandiri: So we're taking the opportunity to do this community call while we're both
Istora Mandiri: Currently in Prague, attending conference here.
Istora Mandiri: We also have on this call some… Long-time contributors?
Istora Mandiri: Shall we say hello, to Wiedergarten? How you doing?
Istora Mandiri: I think we're on mute at the moment.
weder: Yo, how's everyone?
weder: Recall.
Istora Mandiri: Good to see you again, after a while.
Istora Mandiri: Glad you could join.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah.
weder: I apologize, not always able to make it, but it's good to see another fresh face we haven't seen in a while as well.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, just like old times.
Istora Mandiri: We also have WeGo.
w1g0: Hello, everybody.
Istora Mandiri: Here we go. Good to see you.
Istora Mandiri: And maybe we'll try and do these calls at different time zones occasionally in the future, so that people from Europe can join us more easily, and
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, just vary in terms of, potential joiners.
Istora Mandiri: So, this week,
Istora Mandiri: We have just a couple of items that maybe we can talk about, but there's also just, obviously, every time, general floor for people that can bring anything they want to talk about.
Istora Mandiri: On the agenda I have lined up is the new website.
Istora Mandiri: And how we can tackle this.
Istora Mandiri: And what kind of content we can add or remove, and what features we can focus on.
Istora Mandiri: And I also wanted to take the opportunity, as Diego's here, to get into some more deep.
Istora Mandiri: technical…
Istora Mandiri: understandings, particularly when it comes to some of the decision-making for future Ethereum Classic features. We might touch on,
Istora Mandiri: DevP2P.
Istora Mandiri: and the option in front of us in terms of F69, or potentially something that's more specific to Ethereum Classic.
Istora Mandiri: So, we can talk about that.
Istora Mandiri: Either first, or after we talk about the website, or if there's anything else you guys want to bring up.
Istora Mandiri: It's been a while since we've heard from
Istora Mandiri: Weedergen and WeGo, so do you guys have anything that you would like to talk about?
Istora Mandiri: Well, we sh…
weder: I think we should do your normal rounds, and then we can talk about network upgrades later, if everyone is interested.
Istora Mandiri: Sounds good. We go.
w1g0: Yeah, for me, the order is not really important,
w1g0: So, I have some things that I would like to discuss, concerning, the website, Discord, and, also, the centralized nature of GitHub, how…
w1g0: We can, improve that format as well.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, that sounds…
Istora Mandiri: Intriguing. What do you have in mind with the GitHub stuff? Because it is actually quite a pertinent topic.
Istora Mandiri: That I've been thinking about as well, and particularly how we move forward, with this apparent deadlock between GitHub maintainers and
Istora Mandiri: the whole Olympia, no Olympia…
Istora Mandiri: schism that's currently going on, and how we move forward in that. So, if you have any, ideas.
Istora Mandiri: Why don't you, let us know.
w1g0: Well, first of all, we have the, repositories.
w1g0: Each have their own purpose, but they also have, all have their own governance, and, I think it, is not really clear who is…
w1g0: yeah, maintaining which repo. So, I think the… the nature, it should be transparent that, the… who is actually able to have right permissions,
w1g0: In that, in that specific, repo, and also to…
w1g0: Bring on more people that can,
w1g0: That can sign, so that we are not… In this, issue that…
w1g0: There are not… that it does not stagnate because you need too many people signing, to proceed.
w1g0: And, also, well, yeah, the opposite.
Istora Mandiri: Right. It's quite a… A balance between having enough
Istora Mandiri: like, a minimum quorum in terms of approvals for things to get merged. I think currently on the main website, it's two.
Istora Mandiri: approvals.
Istora Mandiri: but also… Having, not too many, such that nothing gets merged.
Istora Mandiri: And I think historically, it was 2, because…
Istora Mandiri: based on the number of active contributors, it kind of fluctuates and settles somewhere, and it just happened to be two. Maybe that's too high, but I think in the current environment, it's…
Istora Mandiri: Better to have a stalemate than one side, like, dictating.
Istora Mandiri: Everything that's on the website.
Istora Mandiri: And that's also why, like, having 3…
Istora Mandiri: People that are, like, coordinating to push things forward is also a problem.
Istora Mandiri: So… Ideally.
Istora Mandiri: I think after this call, I… I mean, I can tell you right now from… from my understanding, so with the website repo.
Istora Mandiri: I'm an administrator on that repo, which means I can decide which team members are in the website maintainer
Istora Mandiri: Group.
Istora Mandiri: And there's currently, I believe, like.
Istora Mandiri: 7 people, I'll check right now. Most of those people are not… Actively contributing.
Istora Mandiri: So, I'll look right now at the team for Ethereum Classic website.
Istora Mandiri: I think it'd be great to have more contributors, as you mentioned, especially ones that are able to be active and engaged, and ideally help us
Istora Mandiri: Like, not take sides, necessarily, but at least
Istora Mandiri: get us past this deadlock phase. Somehow.
Istora Mandiri: And having, like, a neutral third party that's…
Istora Mandiri: I guess a bit like you, Wego, or Wiedergarten, being, like, committed long-term.
Istora Mandiri: Might be helpful in this scenario.
Istora Mandiri: So let me just open up the Teams… So…
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, in the website maintainers team, there's actually 10 people, and that includes, Diego, Firo, myself, Elaine, Bob Sunwell's still there, I guess…
Istora Mandiri: That can be, updated.
Istora Mandiri: Kimmy?
Istora Mandiri: Cody?
Istora Mandiri: Keith Hall Barnett, The Enthusiastic As, and Christopher Mercer.
Istora Mandiri: So that's all the people in the…
Istora Mandiri: website team that have the ability to approve merge requests, basically. Pull requests.
Istora Mandiri: And if two of them agree.
Istora Mandiri: It's a little bit more complex than that, but basically.
Istora Mandiri: If one of the people that have made a pull request
Istora Mandiri: And one other person approves, that's not enough to get something merged, it has to be…
Istora Mandiri: two separate… Maintainers to approve.
Istora Mandiri: And that means that right now, like.
Istora Mandiri: if either side of the active Olympia debate participants
Istora Mandiri: Submits a pull request, it's unlikely to get approved, because you need at least two people.
Istora Mandiri: If that makes sense.
Istora Mandiri: Above me, basically, is the GitHub admin, and I believe that Cody is one of those. So Cody, has full admin…
Istora Mandiri: Right? As far as I understand, I'm not sure, and it'd be good if, we could get, like, an organization diagram to confirm
Istora Mandiri: What roles different people have.
Istora Mandiri: But basically, Cody, I believe, has the ability to…
Istora Mandiri: Remove anyone from any team, and…
Istora Mandiri: Re-ascribe which teams have right access to the repos.
Istora Mandiri: So that is my understanding.
Istora Mandiri: of… who controls the GitHub repos, basically?
weder: So, I think I understand the problem is that there's kind of a deadlock on some of your proposals. I don't know if the one that you sent for switching the Discord again went through, or if that's the one that you're talking about.
weder: But I'm not sure if it's possible to have an actual neutral participant in the sense that you're trying to say, because I think…
weder: that people are going to be picking sides on this, and the idea that one person is going to be accepted by both sides as a neutral party, I don't see anyone, at least right now, in the field of candidates that could be like that. The closest, I would say, is Cody.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, in terms of, like, neutrality on the Olympia topic, a lot of the pull requests are basically…
Istora Mandiri: Determined based on Whether it's, like, If it's concerning Olympia.
Istora Mandiri: I think it's, like, automatically a bit controversial, and for that reason, I've been, like.
Istora Mandiri: intentionally not approving things that may mislead people into thinking that Olympia is further ahead than it is.
Istora Mandiri: And then, contrary to that, like, the Olympia guys don't seem to be approving anything that's not related to Olympia.
w1g0: What I want to say on the Olympia, debate is that
w1g0: While, the elephant in the room is, the funding, they have a proposal.
w1g0: Which is heavily critiqued, because it violates the fundamentals.
w1g0: But in the meantime, there's also no counter-position made, so they are trying to solve a problem that no one else is solving at the moment.
Istora Mandiri: So, actually, myself and Diego published a ECIP called 1120, which is the…
Istora Mandiri: basically counterproposal to Olympia in terms of the mechanism of 1559.
Istora Mandiri: So there is another option on the table, and that did finally get merged after a while.
Istora Mandiri: Going back to the ownership structure, I've just found that Elaine… Mikey O?
Istora Mandiri: and Cody are basically the admins of the…
Istora Mandiri: Ethereum Classic repos, so there's 3 of them.
w1g0: Okay.
w1g0: Well, it's not only for the… because Wither Garden, pointed out for the ECIPs, but it's not only, for, that repo that we are…
w1g0: having some delays, I saw that on the website. There were two, requests for adding it in the applications. There, there was CryptoFlower and Saturn text.
w1g0: But they're still not being approved, while they only need two signatures. If somebody not agrees, okay, that's fine, put a comment, but nobody… I thought you signed one of them.
w1g0: So, that's, that's, in my…
w1g0: opinion, an issue. On the volunteer repo, I have, made a request, so, if volunteers are not being welcomed, you're not gonna grow your user base.
Istora Mandiri: So, yeah.
Istora Mandiri: With reference to those two additional applications.
Istora Mandiri: I approve both of those, and just waiting for another approval. They seem to be non-controversial, not related to Olympia, so the only reason they're not being approved, I think, is just lack of…
Istora Mandiri: activity. So it'd be good if we could get some, as mentioned, more active maintainers on the website,
Istora Mandiri: Did you create that pull request on volunteer?
Istora Mandiri: Recently? Or where is that?
w1g0: I created… I didn't… yeah, I made an issue. I don't think it's needed to be a pull request. I didn't see that in the,
w1g0: in the README that it needed to be a pull request, so…
Istora Mandiri: No, you're right, you're right, I think. And, yeah, this is something that one of the
Istora Mandiri: organization admins, i.e. Elaine, Miko, or Cody, would need to approve.
Istora Mandiri: And maybe it's just not on their radar yet, so I will…
Istora Mandiri: Literally right now, CC Cody into the comments on that.
Istora Mandiri: So maybe he'll get back to us on whether Wigo can join once again as a volunteer.
Istora Mandiri: For people that are kind of, like, recently joining Ethereum Classic.
Istora Mandiri: We go, could you, like, maybe give just a summary of how you've been contributing in the past?
w1g0: Well, my contributions, in the past, have been limited, to…
w1g0: maintaining the Ethereum Classic website. I've been a moderator on the Discord. I've been a very,
w1g0: Limited time and admin, on that same Discord.
w1g0: And, I did some hard fork,
w1g0: coordination, in the sense that I did the transcripts, for the dev meetings, so that's, my,
w1g0: My contributions, so far.
Istora Mandiri: And this was… would be around,
Istora Mandiri: 2020-ish, I guess, till 22, if I remember correctly.
Istora Mandiri: Or a bit earlier as well?
w1g0: Oh, I, I… I have no idea, about time.
w1g0: Time flies.
Istora Mandiri: Indeed. But it's good to have you back.
Istora Mandiri: And, you, you also… I think maybe if you are…
Istora Mandiri: potentially becoming more involved once again. Like, the Discord front is another…
Istora Mandiri: element that I think could also use some attention, and I think your experience there could be quite valuable.
w1g0: Well, yeah, it all depends a bit on, on how this,
w1g0: evolves, because, well, another thing that I have noticed is, that Meal Bits, Chris Yogas,
w1g0: They all left maintainers.
w1g0: Grayscale funding, I stopped. These are some fundamental…
w1g0: changes, I believe, that are not…
w1g0: Really, bad news, but they… are… Moell.
w1g0: Not… not really optimal as well.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, that's true. But I think with all… with all change, like, there's also opportunity.
Istora Mandiri: So… like, it seems that ETC Co-op, or at least from what I understand from Cody's,
Istora Mandiri: intentions that he's shared on Discord, is that the ETC COP would be winding down.
Istora Mandiri: Probably sometime this year.
Istora Mandiri: So that means that, yeah, the…
Istora Mandiri: The volunteer community and potentially other sources of funding will need to be figured out.
Istora Mandiri: I'm confident that there will be solutions to that, and that's partly why I'm stepping up and trying to be involved more and more, and doing these calls.
Istora Mandiri: As well as other things in the background, which…
Istora Mandiri: Hopefully, we'll be able to announce soon.
Istora Mandiri: in terms of the deadlock, though.
Istora Mandiri: I do think that even if
Istora Mandiri: the person that comes in is not 100% neutral and has an opinion, like, everyone has opinions, right? But…
Istora Mandiri: Being, like, having some skin in the game, and having, like, proof of contributions before.
Istora Mandiri: Will definitely help in terms of…
Istora Mandiri: Being an active maintainer, and having a voice in that discussion.
Istora Mandiri: Because… really, I don't think it's necessarily… a problem… based on… like…
Istora Mandiri: the community doesn't know what to do. It's more just, there's not that many people that are active maintainers, and that's been, like, an opportunity,
Istora Mandiri: for one side or the other to be pushed without really much engagement with the wider community. So I think right now is really a good time for more of those voices to be heard.
Istora Mandiri: as maintainers.
w1g0: Well, the… if… The ETC co-op is going away, and there's another party stepping up.
w1g0: That's, well, it's replacing the central entity with another central entity.
w1g0: in… in an ideal world, we would have, several entities, like, while the other, was not really, ideal as well. But I really liked the…
w1g0: How can I say the…
w1g0: the ecosystem when, Charles, Oskinson was there with their Mantis team, and this coordination, and all… all… it was,
w1g0: it was interesting. The only thing that was not that interesting was that the Mantis team was not really on top of things, and they were more asking.
w1g0: questions, but if you have two teams that are knowledgeable, you can have, interesting discussions, and I think that was, lacking in the past.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, and I do actually think that, if anything, this Olympia, Period. Has… Caused a lot of…
Istora Mandiri: Activity. Almost like kicking the hornet's nest and creating either people responding or, like, at least some activity.
Istora Mandiri: And, again, like, I do appreciate that Olympia authors have
Istora Mandiri: made an effort to do something. And that in itself is… A good sign that…
Istora Mandiri: at least something's happening, and us responding to that is also a good sign. Myself responding to that is also a good sign, so…
Istora Mandiri: The only thing that I really hope we can get back to is having this dialogue, and…
Istora Mandiri: Currently, people are not speaking to each other, and that…
Istora Mandiri: prevents any progress, basically. And it's…
Istora Mandiri: it's gonna be difficult to move forward unless we start… restart that dialogue. And that can be done on purely technical conversations without having any, necessarily.
Istora Mandiri: personal engagement on a… Like, it can be just purely conceptual engagement, I think.
Istora Mandiri: As a… as a next step forward.
Istora Mandiri: And part of that is… I think leading us nicely into…
Istora Mandiri: The first… or maybe we can start talking about this technical…
Istora Mandiri: element of the agenda, on F… 69.
Istora Mandiri: Which, I was talking in the Olympia Discord earlier today.
Istora Mandiri: And Cody was mentioning about, some… I'll read the quote verbatim.
Istora Mandiri: So… on the topic of why Cody was not joining these community calls.
Istora Mandiri: He basically said that,
Istora Mandiri: He's thinking about the depth and breadth of
Istora Mandiri: the tree search during healing of SnapSync.
Istora Mandiri: F69 plus behavior during handshake.
Istora Mandiri: DNS versus discovery for peer discovery.
Istora Mandiri: And… He said that some things, he doesn't care about other people's opinions, but some things he does.
Istora Mandiri: And the community call was not a place to have this conversation.
Istora Mandiri: So I thought it might be nice for us to have this conversation.
Istora Mandiri: And given that we have Diego.
Istora Mandiri: With us, who has written on the topic, on… F69, I thought, Why don't we…
Istora Mandiri: potentially move things forward by starting a purely technical discussion? Yeah, absolutely.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, just, two weeks ago, I started to…
Istora Mandiri: kind of research. Yeah, we were thinking about upcoming network upgrades, and what to include, and what to… can be delayed, and so on. So one of the things that popped out was, this change that, Ethereum made, on their
Istora Mandiri: network layer by upgrading their version of the protocol, and so, right now, the consensus on Ethereum Classic runs on top of the ETH68 specification.
Istora Mandiri: And that change will be, like, or should be discussed as part of a network upgrade.
Istora Mandiri: It's not just that, like.
Istora Mandiri: one team or one person could decide on what to do with the network layer. So, yeah, just for having some context or more information, it's that, like.
Istora Mandiri: like, two, two weeks ago, I started this research.
Istora Mandiri: And… and I posted, an article, I, I'm just, opened a substack.
Istora Mandiri: So we can share the link in the notes. But, basically, there I went through, like, why it's not a good idea of, adopting the changes on ETH69 for a proof-of-work network.
Istora Mandiri: Basically, the main change there, or the thing that will prevent it to be an option for proof-of-work network, is that, in 69, they dropped the total difficulty from the status message.
Istora Mandiri: And that changed a lot, and it makes sense for a proof-of-stake chain, because they don't need it, and actually, they had set a total terminal difficulty.
Istora Mandiri: So… For them, that… for them, that was just noise. So they remove it.
Istora Mandiri: There were some other things that may be positive for a protocol.
Istora Mandiri: In, in the, new version, like, for example, dropping bloom filters on…
Istora Mandiri: Things like that, that will…
Istora Mandiri: shrink the size of the packages, and I think that's… that's good, but the problem about adopting 69 in the same way that it was published for Ethereum is that
Istora Mandiri: They are basically dropping the total difficulty there.
Istora Mandiri: The problems that are tied to… to it is that… well, basically, it's an historical thing, it's an historical situation that has been…
Istora Mandiri: settled a long time ago. There was a back and forth in the past, about, this very same…
Istora Mandiri: field, and, like, the… well, this is more extensively in,
Istora Mandiri: like, explain in… in my article. But basically.
Istora Mandiri: it… the first version was, 61, ETH61, then, it didn't have,
Istora Mandiri: It had… initially, it had total difficulty, then they removed it in 62.
Istora Mandiri: And then I think it was added back later on. Basically, that change was made in 2015, so that's when the total difficulty was finally added.
Istora Mandiri: That was for… for solving, and…
Istora Mandiri: like, the bootstrapping of a node. Basically.
Istora Mandiri: it will… so it… this exists way before the specification of a SnapSync, so it solves a really early problem about syncing the blockchain and a proof-of-work chain.
Istora Mandiri: Basically, the consensus says that, the…
Istora Mandiri: The canonical chain will be the one with more total difficulty on it.
Istora Mandiri: So, that's what it's, reflected into the network, the networking layer.
Istora Mandiri: So, let's say if we drop that message.
Istora Mandiri: Then, the only thing that we can use for choosing
Istora Mandiri: Which fork to follow will be the longest one.
Istora Mandiri: And that's…
Istora Mandiri: That's not the right signal for a proof-of-wall network. Because, for example, if you are syncing from scratch, and you have to pick on which node to follow.
Istora Mandiri: If you only choose, by… by the longest one, which… which one of your nodes has the longest chain.
Istora Mandiri: And you pick the longest one, that longest one could trick you and build a really long… really long chain, but with really low difficulty.
Istora Mandiri: And that would be a problem.
Istora Mandiri: So…
Istora Mandiri: This decision of following the terminal difficulty will be that, okay, the first thing is that you have to trust.
Istora Mandiri: Which node to follow.
Istora Mandiri: But with the messages itself, you will be able to…
Istora Mandiri: to prove that you are able to reach the announced total difficulty. So basically, that's why it's so important to have the total difficulty as part of the status message.
Istora Mandiri: And… So, for SnapSync, that came way later in this…
Istora Mandiri: This, research, or this development of the network protocol.
Istora Mandiri: It's not a huge problem, because you're already starting from a network that is advanced in total difficulty terms.
Istora Mandiri: So… In that case, you can say that you are kind of safe.
Istora Mandiri: Because you will have to replicate a network that is longer, but at the same time has enough terminal difficulty.
Istora Mandiri: Because at some point, you will have to complete, what you are snap-syncing.
Istora Mandiri: And you will check
Istora Mandiri: the upcoming, blocks to connect into your, into your chain, and your chain will not accept
Istora Mandiri: Blocks with… without a proper…
Istora Mandiri: terminal difficulty. So, in that case, you can say, yeah, we are sort of safe, but the main problem arises on the… on the full sync.
Istora Mandiri: So, basically, that's a brief explanation on why it's not a good idea.
Istora Mandiri: That being said.
Istora Mandiri: And what I said at the beginning, there are certain things that are interesting, on ETH69 and that could be adopted.
Istora Mandiri: But if we want to do that, it might be the right time to start thinking about having our own protocol.
Istora Mandiri: And that's something that has to be agreed among, the different clients, and… and it's important, and it's something to…
Istora Mandiri: To be decided, and to think about, a migration, and probably, like, a transition, because we will have some times where both
Istora Mandiri: Protocols should coexist, and then eventually one will be dropped in favor of the other.
Istora Mandiri: If we go down that path, probably, like, we can name it ETC slash 1, or ETCS slash any number that we…
Istora Mandiri: decided to be the first one, the first protocol that will be native for EDC.
Istora Mandiri: In that one, we will, adopt these changes, like, dropping, them…
Istora Mandiri: Some things of, of,
Istora Mandiri: like, like, the Bloom filters, also some things that is… they are for history spire, that are, like, there are… those are features that we don't have yet, but, Ethereum has the building and putting the building blocks.
Istora Mandiri: For… for in the future, maybe, discussing about,
Istora Mandiri: expired in the history, but those are things that we can put in place. But I think that's part of a broader conversation, and… but I think it has to be treated in the same way as any other protocol upgrade, and that's the way, as Ethereum has been
Istora Mandiri: Doing for this type of changes.
Istora Mandiri: Because basically, in the end, it could, result into chain split. It will not be strictly a consensus one, but it will be, like, at the communication or networking layer.
Istora Mandiri: So, yes, I think it will be good if people are interested in this to read the article I put in. I think it's, yeah, has some interesting information. I made some…
Istora Mandiri: diagrams there to… to explain more how it works, how it all works. But, yeah, in a not-so-small nutshell, I think that's… that's all.
Istora Mandiri: Could you, give, like, a… just a… To step back, for… for the…
Istora Mandiri: from a higher level view, like, how does DevP2P And the protocol?
Istora Mandiri: like, interact with each other in the client. And… Given that the… Like, these are two separate…
Istora Mandiri: layers, DevP2P not being part of the core protocol. Yes.
Istora Mandiri: So, you have… first, you have the, like, a discovery protocol, which is the Catmelia, and this exchange of messages that you have… you send a hello, then you receive a ping, and you respond with a pong, and then you will be asked for your neighbors, and all that.
Istora Mandiri: Once that connection is established is when the secondary protocol kicks in, and that's when you start talking to peers, and then it's
Istora Mandiri: like, basically, When you pick up which, node to follow among your networks, or the ones that you…
Istora Mandiri: You already know.
Istora Mandiri: And the worry is that if you are preferentially communicating with the wrong
Istora Mandiri: peer, because it's advertising information that's less relevant to proof of work. Yep.
Istora Mandiri: that could cause issues with syncing. Yes, I mean, that node will probably follow what the longest chain. I mean, and there is also something interesting about how, and this is also part of your portfolio, how a client should decide
Istora Mandiri: The first thing that they do is also exchanging capabilities, and they will pick the biggest one.
Istora Mandiri: So, if we have, like, two clients, or we have, yeah, two clients with, 69, in this case, implemented, they will prefer connecting among them using 69.
Istora Mandiri: And that will create, like, a… like, a cluster in a network, like a communication among them only.
Istora Mandiri: And that's also a risk, and it's a… it's definitely an attack vector. I see.
Istora Mandiri: And what would be the motivation for going to 69 from what we have now? Like, apart from the…
Istora Mandiri: The state… the bloom filter removal.
Istora Mandiri: Is there, like, conceivably some, like, interoperability path potential that's beneficial to follow Eth long-term? Well…
Istora Mandiri: Not necessarily at this level, because they are dropping a lot of things that are,
Istora Mandiri: not important for them. Like, for example, it has been signaled… it's signaled that, in the upcoming
Istora Mandiri: release versions of it, they were going to drop messages that are really important for the synchronization of a proof of our chain, basically a proof-of-work chain.
Istora Mandiri: Which is the advertisement of new blogs and new blog hashes, because now they… they got that information from the consensus layer, so they don't need those messages anymore.
Istora Mandiri: So, like, following blindly what Ethereum does is, like, a dead end, basically, because, I mean, they are going through their own agenda of, like, dropping everything they don't need, which makes sense.
Istora Mandiri: But, yeah, it doesn't make sense to follow them blindly in this…
Istora Mandiri: In this particular case. Right. And the interoperability benefits that you would get from other parts of the EVM, like smart contracts, they don't apply. Yeah, no. Because we're just talking between ETC nodes. We don't need to be compatible with Ethereum nodes at all. Yeah, no, not anymore. I think, actually.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, it could be positive, because when you're syncing, you're getting a lot of noise from…
Istora Mandiri: From other nodes that are not Specifically,
Istora Mandiri: for ETC, so I think it might be actually beneficial.
Istora Mandiri: Right. So, instead of trying to follow the F6970 path.
Istora Mandiri: it's better to just start our own with ETC One. Yeah, probably. And then we can design it specifically for ETC's needs, and maybe adopt future changes.
Istora Mandiri: But primarily, like, not try to…
Istora Mandiri: Fight or work around a protocol that's not designed for proof of work.
Istora Mandiri: Yes, and basically, it's important to…
Istora Mandiri: I mean, to… to be aware of that this very same protocol is the same one that has been serving the network for the last more than 10 years. So we have been on top of this protocol for… I'm checking the dates here, for 11 years.
Istora Mandiri: The very same one.
Istora Mandiri: So, like, rushing now on changing it, yeah, it has… it has to be something that has to be really well thought and discussed. Right.
Istora Mandiri: Is this the kind of… Change, assuming it doesn't require a hard fork.
Istora Mandiri: That would make more sense to do in a…
Istora Mandiri: Like, non… if you're gonna do an upgrade.
Istora Mandiri: don't tie it to a hard fork, right? You could… you could do it at any time, essentially, and you could do it in a way that's easier to…
Istora Mandiri: Like, in a gradiented way.
Istora Mandiri: Like, so you're not just switching everything in one go, in one upgrade? Yes, yes, and… yeah, and that's interesting. Yeah, with the proper coordination.
Istora Mandiri: like… Different or multiple protocols could coexist, and that's an interesting path forward.
Istora Mandiri: for these type of changes, because, I mean, you may have part of the network connecting or exchanging messages in one version of the protocol, and some others with the other, and… yeah, that's something that can be done, and… And you could have it as a feature flag that people opt into? Yep.
Istora Mandiri: And then upgrade in a much safer way.
Istora Mandiri: Yes, actually, like, for example, Besu, they have,
Istora Mandiri: The flag that, that says what's the maximum version
Istora Mandiri: Of the protocol. I mean, of course, if we are changing the prefix, and not being ETH and being ETC, and, well.
Istora Mandiri: probably there should be… there will be some things that have to be adjusted, but, overall, the mechanisms are there. I don't know exactly about the other plans, but I know for sure that Besu has that flag.
Istora Mandiri: Could you, explain, like, the worst case scenario in terms of an actual attack?
Istora Mandiri: That might happen if…
Istora Mandiri: there was an Ethereum Classic client using S69. Yes, I mean, the worst, thing that could happen will be that, you could create a cluster
Istora Mandiri: Of, like, a completely new state among a set of clients that they never realized that they had been tricked by.
Istora Mandiri: Malicious, player that they announced a really high block number.
Istora Mandiri: with, like, a fakely, created… I mean, it had… I mean, it would be actual proof of work, but it would be probably way…
Istora Mandiri: less difficulty than the… than the longest chain, or the canonical one. I don't want to be the… the longest one, the canonical one. The heaviest chain. The heaviest chain, yes.
Istora Mandiri: So this would create a chain split based on the network partition? Yes, yes. So, yeah, that's… that will be the main… the main problem. Yeah. I see.
Istora Mandiri: And it's particularly… Relevant to SnapSync.
Istora Mandiri: Do I understand that correctly? No, well, no, actually, for SnapSync.
Istora Mandiri: you could say that you will be safe if you upgrade to ETH69. I mean, in terms of ETH69, let's say that happens, and you only have SnapSync as your syncing mechanism, you could say you are… you could be quite safe, because
Istora Mandiri: Even if you get… if you pick
Istora Mandiri: the longest, chain announced by a peer, that peer will have to send you a block that will connect to your existing chain. And for doing that, that, that, malicious had to send you,
Istora Mandiri: A blog with enough difficulty in it.
Istora Mandiri: So, in that case, we can say we are pretty safe.
Istora Mandiri: But, the main problem will be for the full sinks, which…
Istora Mandiri: In my particular opinion, I think full sync is the most important aspect of a blockchain. Right. I agree that it's good to have snap syncs or protocols that are more user-friendly.
Istora Mandiri: But, yes, I have a…
Istora Mandiri: like, I can say quite large,
Istora Mandiri: opinions about, history, Spire, and those sort of things that, yeah, I would probably have to research way more, but so far, I think the most beautiful mechanism that the blockchain has is the full sync property. Right.
Istora Mandiri: Wego, I see you had a question. Did you want to… Jump in now?
w1g0: Yeah, sure. I was wondering, this,
w1g0: Starting from zero, which makes sense, since the consensus mechanism is completely different.
w1g0: if it would have, any complications, implications, for the smart contracts, that get ported from Ethereum, on ETC, if they're…
w1g0: maybe, like, an attack factor, in, I don't know, in different up codes or something, I don't know.
Istora Mandiri: No, no, no, no, thankfully, no, these are two orthogonal.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, aspects of the, of the chain.
Istora Mandiri: Great.
Istora Mandiri: Right, it's really just the network layer, and peer discovery, and syncing. Yeah, it's also about consistency, because, I mean, we have a mechanism, a fork choice mechanism, within the network, the consensus, let's say, which is that you will never connect to your chain
Istora Mandiri: a block that has lesser difficulty than the one that you already know that it's the best one. And if we drop that into the network layer, we will have another
Istora Mandiri: yeah, and another concept there for picking, for picking up, which will be the…
w1g0: I think that would be really interesting, for me personally, I think, and I think it would be helpful for other people that are, less technical.
w1g0: is to have a animated, video on how, a client, miners, knows, distribution of ETC,
w1g0: currency, how this really, works, and maybe how these certain, changes proposed would affect
w1g0: like, people, I think… oh, well, I don't know why this,
w1g0: so little, traction on ETC, but, first of all, it would be that people just follow, the crowd, and they're on EAT.
w1g0: And Solana, I guess,
w1g0: But secondly, I think there's also the history of the 51% attacks.
w1g0: Which maybe are not really clear to people what they are, but…
w1g0: They might, say that, It's,
w1g0: unsafe, and I think that maybe an animation, on the consensus,
w1g0: Would, well, visualize, make it
w1g0: Because, well, we all have different learning styles, and for people who are more visual and auditory, or some documents might not really, explain it well.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, I totally agree, and it kind of ties into the next topic with the website.
Istora Mandiri: if you do check out the article that Diego published, which I'll add to the, the show notes after this call.
Istora Mandiri: There are some diagrams on there that try to explain how the protocol is communicating between peers.
Istora Mandiri: In both 68 and 69.
Istora Mandiri: in a visual way. It's not a video, but yeah, it would be great if there was kind of like a…
Istora Mandiri: Is it 3… 3 blue, 1 brown?
Istora Mandiri: style YouTube video explaining how, the various aspects of ETC actually work under the hood.
Istora Mandiri: Because there's… there are some pretty esoteric stuff in there, and like…
Istora Mandiri: In ETC world, there's probably only a handful of people that really understand how it works, so it'd be good to have more people that do.
Istora Mandiri: Even though it's less technical, and I put myself in that category as well.
Istora Mandiri: And I'm thinking, like, on…
Istora Mandiri: Actually, yeah, before we move on to the website, were there any…
Istora Mandiri: comments or questions about F69 from the… Participants?
w1g0: For me, well, this, sounds,
w1g0: acceptable, but I'm not technical enough to… to understand. I have a broad idea what's happening, but I cannot voice,
w1g0: Any opinions?
Istora Mandiri: Yeah.
Istora Mandiri: So, for a bit of, like, background context, the…
Istora Mandiri: some of the clients that have been worked on by the Olympia guys, are implementing F69.
Istora Mandiri: and it's kind of like a technical decision that I think is worthy of more conversation.
Istora Mandiri: And…
Istora Mandiri: part of the reason that I'm bringing it up here is because Cody specifically mentioned this protocol earlier today as something that, is kind of just decided that's happening.
Istora Mandiri: Similar to Olympia. But I think, definitely.
Istora Mandiri: maybe is not the best choice, and there's definitely room for debate in there, and I think having a forum to discuss those technical aspects is exactly what this call is supposed to be about, and I hope that this forum
Istora Mandiri: Can be hosting that kind of debate as it has done in the past.
Istora Mandiri: But that requires the participation from, from both sides. So…
Istora Mandiri: It's almost like an open invitation to…
Istora Mandiri: even if it's just purely technical discussions, I still think there's value for everyone to participate in them.
Istora Mandiri: And this… F6869 thing is just another one of those examples. And I hope that…
Istora Mandiri: maybe Cody can either…
Istora Mandiri: respond to this in Discord, or maybe even join a call, where we can have these technical debates once again.
w1g0: I want to pick in on that, and I think that Cody is right. I think as
w1g0: there might be, or there probably are, very technical people in the ETC community,
w1g0: I saw it was also a question in the community calls, where should these technical discussions be held? And I think that, that's really for a deaf call, where people are really technical and can…
w1g0: pick up, you… there's no harm in, explaining a technical issue in the community calls.
w1g0: But I don't think that the community call is a good forum, for…
w1g0: Yeah, making decisions on technical issues.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, that's a fair point. If there was a developer call.
Istora Mandiri: I'd be more than happy to join that and discuss things there.
Istora Mandiri: But in lieu of that, this is, like, the only call. So…
Istora Mandiri: There doesn't really seem to be any other option.
Istora Mandiri: than having this call for both the technical side and the community aspect, but I would love to join a developer call as well.
w1g0: Yeah, that's also a historical point, because we have a…
w1g0: For quite some time, a, a dev… a dev chat on the…
w1g0: On the Discord, but it's… it's really not being used,
w1g0: And I think it's more, well, how can I say,
w1g0: something that's… that's not a habit. It was just not a habit for devs to have their discussion.
w1g0: Whether it's for core, protocol, explanations, or for Layer 2 app,
w1g0: questions… well, there was never… there's never been, a back and forth between, like, yeah, how should we do this smart contract, or how should a client, respond to this behavior? Well, that's… that's something I would have
w1g0: thought that would have been interesting to follow, like, somebody who is not technical and is willing to learn. There's not really much documentation around.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, yeah, and this kind of goes into a bigger topic about how the direction of development is
Istora Mandiri: Decided within the community, and previously co-op was almost like… By default.
Istora Mandiri: The funders and deciding direction of the protocol.
Istora Mandiri: But now it's winding up, like, there must be some other way that we can come to these decisions in a decentralized way, ideally.
Istora Mandiri: But again, that requires communication.
Istora Mandiri: So, hopefully that will return.
Istora Mandiri: But you did make a good point about the documentation, and maybe we can now talk about the improvements to the website.
Istora Mandiri: That, the upcoming redesign and basically rebuilding of the whole thing later this year, can address.
Istora Mandiri: Did you have any thoughts on that, Weigo?
Istora Mandiri: Because I know that you were expressing interest in helping with that.
w1g0: Yeah, for me, the main interest is to make the smooth transition from the Gatsby framework to Astro. I don't know if that's already really being decided, if that needs to be decided at all.
w1g0: I think it's a great, solution. I'm in favor of that, and I'm really…
w1g0: offering my service to make that happen, if things need to be rewritten and observed that, transition goes smoothly. How the…
w1g0: well, how the website would look like. I think it would be interesting to have some more technical things that are more dynamic than static.
w1g0: Like, the pricing, like, how many nodes there are, who are, the miners, where are they located on, on a…
w1g0: On a map, so there's some backend stuff, I guess,
w1g0: that's… that's some things that I would like to see. So you can really track to see, is the protocol actually decentralized? Or I remember some phase that…
w1g0: When the difficult, the difficulty, when, some,
w1g0: miners are rogue or attacking the protocol, that it switches to, a higher, consensus, or that you need more percentage to overtake, the…
w1g0: Yeah, I've been out of the loop for some years.
w1g0: So, I have a conceptual understanding, but I don't know the terms.
Istora Mandiri: I think you're talking about mess.
w1g0: Yeah, exactly.
Istora Mandiri: Yep.
Istora Mandiri: Again, that's… mess was happening on the P2P layer, Or…
Istora Mandiri: Yes, yeah, basically that's where it happened, yeah. Right, so that was another non-hard fork.
Istora Mandiri: Yes, yeah, it will give you eventual… yeah. Yeah, definitely, like, it would be awesome to have some more visualization and dashboards, and ideally be able to,
Istora Mandiri: like, show… Things like reorgs, if they happen.
Istora Mandiri: Yes, well, something important to say is that
Istora Mandiri: By now, Mess is deactivated. It's not active by default in the…
Istora Mandiri: corgath version, the latest Corgate patient, and that has been the case for a really long time. That was a decision that
Istora Mandiri: yeah, we published, and we had a public discussion, you can trace it back in GitHub, but overall, the…
Istora Mandiri: The decision was that, yeah, the network is in a completely different state than it used to be when it was activated, and…
Istora Mandiri: Having mess was, kind of a… technical depth.
Istora Mandiri: Because, it diverse a lot from the upstream.
Istora Mandiri: For the work I've been doing on alternative clients, I… I try to keep it.
Istora Mandiri: like,
Istora Mandiri: Disabled by default, but, like, they are being there just in case that we need to coordinate something to enable it.
Istora Mandiri: But, I don't know, that's something I'm probably up to debate. I would vouch for… for removing it completely.
Istora Mandiri: But, out of respect of the community, I let it there.
Istora Mandiri: So… but yeah, that's also… Something else to talk about.
w1g0: if I remember correctly, there was something, that…
w1g0: There were some alarms that were going off if,
w1g0: a reorg happened, and that somebody, I think it was MioBits, that, had to intervene manually.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah.
Istora Mandiri: That was the case in the past, yeah, when the 51% attacks happened.
Istora Mandiri: In what way was he intervening?
Istora Mandiri: He had to coordinate with, yeah, the different stakeholders to basically enable
Istora Mandiri: or deploy a new version. It wasn't there, but it was one of the two.
Istora Mandiri: Right.
Istora Mandiri: That's also, like, an infrastructure thing that… like, human infrastructure, that I think needs… reinforcing.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, absolutely, and… Yeah, I will not say it's centralized, but we need a
Istora Mandiri: like, a common point of communication among different stakeholders for a situation like this one. Yeah.
Istora Mandiri: Unless…
w1g0: That's what I… that's what I meant with, like, it needs to be visualized, that it's decentralized, and the solutions, so that it inspires people that the protocol is safe.
Istora Mandiri: Yes,
Istora Mandiri: Yes, I don't think this… all these communications have been taken, like, in the shadows, but yeah, I mean, all that was traceable on the network activity, but yeah, probably not…
Istora Mandiri: properly… Announced, or… Right. It's a bit of a paradox in… decentralized communities, like, where, like.
Istora Mandiri: Someone kind of has to fill the role of being a single point, or at least a node.
Istora Mandiri: relays information to people. Yeah, and also in those, like, emergency situations, it's kind of important to have a… probably a single criteria to follow, because let's say that we have a dashboard that will alert everyone that we are going under a 51% attack.
Istora Mandiri: And what would be the decision there?
Istora Mandiri: So… I mean, at some point, maybe some… I mean… at least, general agreement on…
Istora Mandiri: Who to follow, will be important, and it's really difficult to plan a protocol for every possible attack there, because basically those… their nature of attacks is that we cannot prevent them.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, we can only imagine what may come, but
Istora Mandiri: So, yes, it's, yeah, it's a tough… Decision.
Istora Mandiri: So yeah, having a nice landing page with
Istora Mandiri: Visually appearing, dynamic stuff, appealing, would be… Great, I think. Yeah.
Istora Mandiri: Definitely, yep.
Istora Mandiri: The other thing I was… thinking about is, like, in the age of AI, like.
Istora Mandiri: To what extent do we utilize AI on the website? I don't think we should be generating slot for everything.
Istora Mandiri: But at the same time, it might be useful to use some features,
Istora Mandiri: For example, like, checking that links are alive.
Istora Mandiri: And potentially translating into different languages.
Istora Mandiri: There's probably some uses of AI that… Basically, nobody is against.
Istora Mandiri: And I think, there might even be the case of, like.
Istora Mandiri: Turning some of the more complicated concepts into easier-to-understand articles using AI.
Istora Mandiri: As a possible… as a possible use of it.
Istora Mandiri: Do you have any opinions, Wigo?
w1g0: Yeah, on the opinion side, regarding which, agent, will be used, and if it's
w1g0: Freeware, or, where the funding comes from, or, well, that…
w1g0: That's, one thing. On the other, I don't… I'm not really, in favor of, AI, because it's,
w1g0: well, quite controversial at the moment, and as ETC is a more conservative,
w1g0: I think, I wouldn't be ashamed to integrate that as,
w1g0: As the last community out there.
weder: I disagree. I think that you can be all for ETC and the principled values that it holds, while still being supportive of the use of AI. I think that human oversight is definitely the most important part, whether it comes to your developing websites or making translations, it's just important that everything gets, like, a second check
weder: from a human, but when it comes to stuff like ETC, where the people who are contributing nowadays are volunteers, if we can triple or quadruple the productivity of the volunteers.
weder: Instead of having to necessarily get more volunteers, it can definitely lessen the load if it can be used productively and used to simply just do things that would take you longer to do without having to take as long to do it.
w1g0: Well, -
w1g0: if I may, pick up on that, on… based on what, Wade regarden is saying, I could, see, use for, let's say, in the Twitter together.
w1g0: application, an AI that is proposing, and that people are,
w1g0: Let's say, rewriting what it says, or…
w1g0: that approve, so that it can pass. In that, I'm… I think it can be useful, because I think that I'm not on X or Twitter or whatever.
w1g0: But I think it can be useful because the proposed tweets were very, very low in the past.
Istora Mandiri: Right, indeed. And yeah, having even just, like, the idea generation on a… and the prompting to actually…
Istora Mandiri: Create tweets on a regular basis.
Istora Mandiri: would, I think, in itself, be useful?
Istora Mandiri: And yeah, as long as a human signs off on it, and it's not completely garbage, I don't see the negative in terms of output.
Istora Mandiri: On the front of, using AI during development, I'm totally for it, and I think that
Istora Mandiri: Like, modern development basically requires
Istora Mandiri: AI, like, almost everyone is going to be using it to some extent, some more than others, but I'm definitely in the leaning into agentic engineering camp.
Istora Mandiri: And if I do work on the website, then that will most certainly be using coding agents,
Istora Mandiri: To help with the migration, even if it's not, like… in the production
Istora Mandiri: side of having, like, a chatbot to talk to ETC or something, but during the development rollout, I'm… I'm definitely pro-AI in that… in that sense.
Istora Mandiri: As long as there's, like, a level of…
Istora Mandiri: quality to the work that's outputted, and, you know, like any tool, it can be abused. So, as long as that's kept in check, then…
Istora Mandiri: like Wiedergarden is saying, it's something that can really help amplify the efforts of the volunteers.
Istora Mandiri: And, with a limited number of volunteers, I think it would be more and more essential for us to lean into these tools to have an effect.
w1g0: I think, I think I already said that I'm not…
w1g0: much in favor of AI, to…
w1g0: implemented really quickly, because I'm more inclined to,
w1g0: Search other volunteers and have a human.
w1g0: Interaction, with everything.
w1g0: And this is based, because I'm, yeah, I'm more an observer, I'm more an analyst, and from the contributions I see, they are very, very low quality, to begin with, and secondly, it's always a human that needs to check.
w1g0: And, that's… while that's great for beginners, I have the impression that, senior,
w1g0: The seniors, really get annoyed by, the low quality, and that they'd rather do it themselves from the first,
w1g0: From the first time.
weder: I think that's an interesting position, but I see it the other way around. The way I see it is that developers who've been doing development for before… since before there was AI,
weder: they understand how to work a codebase, they can do that by hand. They don't need AI. So when they… when AI steps into the picture, I feel like… and you may not have experienced this yourself, but at least for me.
weder: what happened was, is that it essentially took over certain parts of things that would… the time-consuming parts of things that I would typically not exactly enjoy the most doing.
weder: are effectively stripped out, and it's replaced by my, essentially, mostly my oversight, of what's going on. And I… and I'm not sure about the future, but
weder: The way things are moving right now, and it depends on you, you know, how you see things.
weder: AI is…
weder: becoming something that if you don't adapt to, then you may fall behind, and you may not, you may not be seen as adapt as people who are both good at development, and also good with artificial intelligence to help them. And the people who are just starting to learn how to code now.
weder: they are at a disadvantage because they are used to having artificial intelligence there, and they're not used to being able to debug things and to do things manually, and they are going to learn from the start to rely on AI to fix those things. So, from your point, I agree that it does cause quality issues, but I would say that comes from the more newer developed
weder: developers, and it's more important that we just try to expand, to give our knowledge from before AI and show them that you have to learn the ropes a little bit yourself before you incorporate AI, or else you're not going to understand what's going on in the back end and what's going on behind the scenes.
w1g0: Yeah, that makes perfect sense, but in the same way, Ethereum Classic is not the, the apex chain out there, so, maybe the timing is not,
w1g0: so crucial.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, I think Wiedergarden, you hit the nail on the head there, and I agree with your analysis. In terms of the timing for ETC,
Istora Mandiri: I'd say, like, really, we just need to get things done, and if these tools are helping us achieve that with the limited resources we have, then that's a good thing.
Istora Mandiri: I actually look forward, Wego, to showing you what is possible, with These agentic engineering tools.
Istora Mandiri: in the right hands, and I'm thinking, like, the amount of hours I spent on the current version of the website just doing…
Istora Mandiri: complete monkey work, basically, aligning divs, etc, is something that now takes seconds instead of hours and hours, and that time saved can be going to other things and more productive things, so…
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, I… all I'd ask is keep an open mind, and…
Istora Mandiri: Let's, work closely, and hopefully you'll be able to see some of the power of this technology, if we're working together on the website.
Istora Mandiri: At least in terms of the… the less essential stuff.
Istora Mandiri: And when it comes to the core clients, this is where it's really an important question of how much AI is too much AI, and what kind of quality controls are necessary.
Istora Mandiri: Because it's not just a website, it's not just a contract even, but it's the whole protocol.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, I think, when… I mean, my opinion in this is about curation of the content. That's, the most important thing.
Istora Mandiri: And it will also depend on how…
Istora Mandiri: large is the codebase that we are building on, like, for example.
Istora Mandiri: The codebase for the Nethermine plugin is less than 2,000 lines of code.
Istora Mandiri: Which will be quite sim… quite easily reviewable for any human being,
Istora Mandiri: And I think that's the way to go.
Istora Mandiri: For larger code bases, it may be, like, a challenge itself.
Istora Mandiri: like, for example, when I… something that I did when I've been working on, well, GETC, so this new type of revamped version of CoreGet on top of Core Ethereum.
Istora Mandiri: Was to… to build.
Istora Mandiri: diff basis.
Istora Mandiri: So, because the main idea with that work was to try to bring it back, all the changes that were removed by the GoEthereum team.
Istora Mandiri: All the things that were important for a proof-of-work network, and adapting what was necessary
Istora Mandiri: for… for, like, adapting into their new architecture, because, of course, they have been changing things. But what… what I tried was to… well, to… to…
Istora Mandiri: Turn back to life to those, those, commits.
Istora Mandiri: So, kind of reverting them, but in an intelligent way. And during that process, what it did was
Istora Mandiri: To put in place several tools that will create a wiki page with the actual diff.
Istora Mandiri: That will allow anyone to check
Istora Mandiri: If anything had been changed from
Istora Mandiri: The previous state of the codebase.
Istora Mandiri: So, that… will not…
Istora Mandiri: Ensure that, it will be bug-free, but at least it should give us a good signal that it will be in the very same state.
Istora Mandiri: As before the removals.
Istora Mandiri: So, that's where I think it's important, the curation and all the tools that we can build around for humans to validate
Istora Mandiri: what the AI made.
Istora Mandiri: And… and more… moreover, in… in a consensus.
Istora Mandiri: Client.
Istora Mandiri: So, yes, I think that's… that's important, and I agree on both sides. I think it's an amazing tool that allows us to do amazing things.
Istora Mandiri: But the human touch and the eye and the criteria has to still be there.
Istora Mandiri: And we never had to lose that, at least, for now. Yeah. Right. And whilst the AI can…
Istora Mandiri: Create valid code.
Istora Mandiri: it doesn't necessarily have the depth and the historical context to understand what's best for ETC, specifically. I mean, for example, this…
Istora Mandiri: this previous topic of F… F… 69. 69?
Istora Mandiri: It could be the case that maybe an agent decided, okay, this is… let's upgrade, you know? You need to bump the version. And then you just go down that path and spend however many hours implementing that without really under, like, should we do this?
Istora Mandiri: And that's… that's not something that I think that AI is at yet, to make those high-context decisions.
Istora Mandiri: Yes, part of my research was also, like, trying to… to go deep into the… the…
Istora Mandiri: Earlier on the old decisions that lead to the inclusion of
Istora Mandiri: of this, and then was when I realized, okay, yeah, that was there for a reason, and they already had this discussion internally into the Ethereum
Istora Mandiri: groups. So, yeah, that was already settled. But it's, yeah, that's something that, yeah, the AI missed.
Istora Mandiri: Probably.
Istora Mandiri: Could be the case. Yup.
Istora Mandiri: And, and yeah, the… heh.
Istora Mandiri: It could be the case that in the far future, like, the whole protocol is controlled by agents, but I really don't think we're there yet, and we have to recognize the limitations of the tools that exist as they do today.
Istora Mandiri: And I see them as just… Like, extremely good code completion.
Istora Mandiri: But not necessarily, decision-making.
Istora Mandiri: Tools.
Istora Mandiri: And depending on the complexity and importance of the software that's been worked on, I think…
Istora Mandiri: humans definitely still have a large part to play. Yeah. And we'll do for the foreseeable future.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, something like, for example, that an AI is… well, in my experience, has not been incredible, was that…
Istora Mandiri: Like, when you're working, for example, in a large codebase written by humans like BESU, and you want to introduce a refactor that has to be readable for reviewers, that you have to convince to include it.
Istora Mandiri: It's not really good, because it doesn't think in the same way that a human does.
Istora Mandiri: So, you have to kind of manually go through all the transformation, probably to reach out the proposition that it made, but you have to do it in a way that will convince, and during the process, you will get convinced also that it's,
Istora Mandiri: It could change, like, taking all the guardrails that you will…
Istora Mandiri: take for any call that you had written manually, so I think, like, for example, that's… it's another example where the human touch is really important, because in the end.
Istora Mandiri: There are still humans merging code, and you have to think of them.
Istora Mandiri: And the best usage of their time as reviewers and maintainers of the codebase. So it's not just about, throwing up, like.
Istora Mandiri: a pull request with a thousand lines changing, because, I mean, that will be actually disrespectful for the time of the reviewers.
Istora Mandiri: So yeah, that's also something else that we have to keep an eye on. Right, right. And actually, it was a time that I was talking with a Nethermine team.
Istora Mandiri: About some pull requests that I had to send for… for the…
Istora Mandiri: ETC plugin to work well with their codebase, and they told me that I had to, like.
Istora Mandiri: signal to them to send them a message with a pull request, because they were receiving that many pull requests coming from AI that was impossible for them to handle, and…
Istora Mandiri: As they are, like, really good professionals, they had to… to go through all the… all the proposals.
Istora Mandiri: But, yeah, most of them were garbage or on this shape. I mean, someone ran an agent against their codebase, and who knows which prompt they use, and okay, they decide to just send a pull request.
Istora Mandiri: So, yeah, so the human part there is important. Right. And unless you have experience working with the codebase and the protocol.
Istora Mandiri: Yeah, and also having experience reviewing other people's code and all of that. So, yeah, I think that's still the human part. It's there, and it's quite important. Right. So even if it's easy to generate a ton of new features and have
Istora Mandiri: I don't know, like, 10 pull requests a day.
Istora Mandiri: Through agentic work.
Istora Mandiri: that doesn't actually improve the speed at which you can merge them. Yeah. You still need the human in the loop there.
Istora Mandiri: And this slow, methodical, Human-based approach, especially for the critical
Istora Mandiri: lines of code in the clients, I think is going to be important to keep around for a long time.
Istora Mandiri: Okay, so we are, like… it's been a good discussion, it's been…
Istora Mandiri: more than an hour now, so I think maybe now's a good time to wrap things up. Would…
Istora Mandiri: Is there any other comments or last things to mention before we do so from… from… to join us?
w1g0: I have, nothing else to add. I just, wanted to, ask you what the counter… the ECIP for the counter-proposal for Olympia, was.
Istora Mandiri: That number was 1120.
Istora Mandiri: Awesome. Chocolate.
Istora Mandiri: ECIP 1120. I'll add that to the show notes, which you'll find in the transcript.
w1g0: Thank you.
Istora Mandiri: No problem.
weder: Nothing for me, thank you so much.
Istora Mandiri: Okay, thank you both for joining, and…
Istora Mandiri: The next community call will be 2 weeks in the future, probably at the regular time, sorry, Europe, of 0 to 100 hours UTC on Friday, 2 weeks' time. So, thank you for everyone participating today. It's been a…
Istora Mandiri: A deeply stimulating call.
Istora Mandiri: So, yeah, see you next time. Thanks for joining. Till then, stay classy. Thank you.
w1g0: Thanks for the discussion. Bye.